[Music]
I'm dealing with the future of the
planet
[Music]
under necessary shot to the system I am
human evolutionary change
bulletproof super human hell are you bad
guy the mission has been compromised
we need help
[Music]
our targets name is Brixton he's a ghost
we're gonna need the best trackers in
the business Luke Hobbs on what you call
a nice cold can of whoop-ass career
lawmen always gets his guy we're gonna
need to operate outside the system
Deckard Shaw I'm what you might call a
champagne robot you have no idea what
we're dealing with
Pop's sure
sure what
[Music]
three sharks will kill a man there we go
everybody is Charlie happy Superbowl
weekend they finally started to drop the
Superbowl trailers starting with fast
and furious Hobbs and Shaw so if you
didn't know this is the rock in Jason
Statham's fast and furious spin-off
based on their characters from Fast 8
because it takes place after that movie
so I'll explain what's going on there's
a couple new additions to the franchise
and there's a whole bunch of news about
the Fast & Furious franchise in general
so it's Super Bowl weekend if you're
finding my channel for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all those
videos so biggest thing Hobbs and Shaw
takes place after the events of fast 8
they sort of won their freedom from the
government for saving the world during
the course of that movie because that
was the one where Vin Diesel's character
was forced by Charlize Theron to turn to
the dark side or make it seem like he
turned to the dark side and betray all
his friends so it was all about family
like he had to pretend like he hated
them all then he came back because of
the surprise love child that he found
about with his former lover from one of
the previous movies so surprise Vin
Diesel baby during the Fast & Furious
franchise they need that baby Brian
after Paul Walker's character so now
there is a new Brian in the Fast &
Furious franchise that will see again
probably during fast 9 because Hobbs and
Shaw is a spinoff they're making fast 9
right now I think that they're getting
ready to shoot it or they've already
started to shoot it because Vin Diesel
just posted something on Instagram with
Michelle Rodriguez like getting ready to
start our next Fast & Furious movie so
presumably that movie will take place
after the events of Hopsin sha like they
all seem to move in a linear fashion
even though we've all been joking like
to slowly move the franchise by the 10th
film into outer space like where do you
take that tenth Fast & Furious film but
even though this is a spin-off
technically it is the 9th Fast & Furious
movie it's just that their characters
Hobbs and Shah from fate of the Furious
would probably one of the best things
about that movie and they had so much
chemistry together that by the time that
they started dropping trailers for that
like the minute you see them go at each
other in the prison people were
screaming spin up like they just seems
like those two characters would work
well together in a future movie so of
course
the rock who has really big pull at the
studio and he's just a really big
box-office draw for people it's like
hell yeah I'll do a spinoff with Jason
Statham Jason Statham has his own giant
fandom if he didn't see the MiG that
movie did gangbusters regardless of what
you thought of the quality of the story
like people will just show up to see
Jason Statham kick ass in movies
regardless of what the movie is actually
about same thing for the rock so of
course they were gonna do Hopson Shaw
there were all these reports of drama
behind the scenes when they were talking
about the spin-off and Vin Diesel
altering cuts of Fast and Furious 8 so
that there wasn't as much rock in it and
there were some of the other stars of
the franchise like Tyrese that were
really upset that the rock was trying to
do a spin-off of their main franchise
it's hard to tell how much of that's
real and actors are actually upset with
each other or if it's all fake beef in
the name of publicity like the rock
comes from the world of wrestling where
you have professional beefs with other
characters as part of a story arc so
it's like eventually they face off in
the ring and they deal with the beef but
the whole deal with this movie is is
that it arose elba gets to be the worst
bad guy of the franchise so far like
that's the whole idea is like every time
they roll out a new bad guy like Jason
Statham's Shaw character used to be the
villain he's actually the guy that
killed Hahn at the end of fast and
furious Tokyo Drift they addressed that
a little bit but that was one of the
narrative ways that they really got fans
to hate his character when he first
debuted like oh he's a threatening
villain because he killed this character
that we all love so much that was fast
and furious seven fast and furious 8 was
where they turned him into the antihero
like will pardon you of your crimes if
you help us take down this even worst
villain who was Charlize Theron Skerritt
er the turns of the movie are pretty
easy to figure out but from this footage
if he didn't recognize her vanessa kirby
is coming in from the mission impossible
franchise she was the white widow during
that movie she was the daughter of the
Maxine character from the first Mission
Impossible movie so we're just paying
off a really big Easter egg and a brand
new character and she was pretty
fantastic she was also in the crown she
did an amazing job so she's a great
actress so of course they wanted to
bring her into the Fast and Furious
franchise but if you didn't hear about
it when she was initially cast she's
actually playing the sister of Shaw's
character so I guess that that means
she's probably gonna wind up banging the
rocks character vision seems like
something that he would do to siya
despite him because the whole trailer is
them being forced to work together and
then playing on those comedic moments
like I hate you
so much I can't believe that we're being
forced to work together so we guess we
might as well make the best of it
so they probably find some common ground
by the end of the film then surprise
twist he winds up sleeping with his
sister which makes him hate him again
and they just carry it forward into the
next film but it seems like what's going
on is that she's part of the family
business remember their mother Jason
Statham and Vanessa Kirby's mother in
the franchise is played by Helen Mirren
she was in fast 8 she helped out Vin
Diesel's character briefly but she paid
reference to shot so they was just like
this big Shaw family within the world of
fast and furious now in vanessa kirby is
now his sister just the newest part of
that of course she's a badass I don't
think you're allowed to bring in a new
family member like that in a movie like
this without them being some crazy level
badass but the rest of the trailer
mostly hype sup what's going on with
Idris Elba's villain character like it
tries to say that he's invincible he
says he's bulletproof that's obviously
because he has some crazy medical
technology that heals him up because you
see all those scars on his back with his
special machine stitching him right here
and it just seems like he has a lot of
really stealth military tech built into
that special black suit that he's
wearing like there's been the whole
trailer talking about how big the rock
is and how crazy he is then he punches
him right across frame like holy crap
how did it ourselves
he's probably just got one of those
special military frames built in with
all those metal parts that enhance the
strength of soldiers they've actually
started to make those for the military
it's sort of like wearing a miniature
version of a mech underneath your
clothing it basically multiplies your
strength
many many fold so that's why it seems
like he's invincible it's just because
he's got all this special metal tech
underneath his clothing that's enhancing
his strength there's something about the
rock jumping off of buildings and fast
and furious movies like they drove the
car across two buildings I think that
was during fast 7 there's typically a
shot like that in all the trailers in
this they obviously because it's Hobbs
and sha they just play on the comedy of
that so the rock jumps over the side and
Jason Statham takes the elevator while
he's cursing him out slowly going down
I don't know how self-contained this is
supposed to be so I don't know if
they're actually gonna have cameos from
the other Fast and Furious franchise
members but based on the behind the
scenes beefs that everyone's talking
about it sounds like it will not like
it'll be relatively self-contained in
those verbally reference what happened
during fast date and they have some
teaser that'll imply the
they'll be coming back in the next fast
and furious movie I think the beauty
largely of films like this is you don't
necessarily need to know what the plot
is to enjoy it like it doesn't
necessarily need to make sense because
they know exactly who their audience is
they know exactly what they want so they
give it to them and that's why the
franchise has become so popular like
they just found their audience like okay
this is the kind of movie that you want
so we're just gonna keep giving that to
you which is why the franchise has had
so much longevity when it turned from
more of a movie about cars in the early
Fast and Furious movie to more of a big
action roller coaster film let me know
what you think about all this I think
also the beauty of the rocks-- movies is
that separately like he has his own
genre in and of himself he's sort of
like the new Schwarzenegger like you
know exactly what kind of movie you're
gonna get when you go to see a movie
with the rock in it what'll be happening
later this weekend is that there was a
new Captain Marvel Super Bowl trailer
that just drops all into a video for
that next and then there'll be Avengers
endgame this weekend I believe maybe a
game of Thrones Season 8 trailer and
then a couple of big Disney trailers so
leave all your requests in the comments
below while you wait for everything
click here for that brand new Captain
Marvel trailer and click here to find
out why Ben Affleck left the Batman role
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]